Vsauce! Kevin here -- Jennifer Thompson
studied every detail of her attacker's face
as she was being sexually assaulted at
knifepoint. His hairline, broad cheekbones,
a mustache that looked like a pencil-thin dirt
smear. She couldn't fight back physically,
but MENTALLY she could memorize every
little detail and bring him to justice.
Police described Jennifer as
the best witness they'd ever
had. Her eyewitness testimony convicted
Ronald Cotton, and he was sentenced to
life in prison plus 50 years despite no
physical evidence linking him to the crime.
There was no evidence because he didn't do it
-- and 11 years later, DNA testing proved it.
So how could the "best witness ever"
get it completely wrong? Why do about
70% of DNA exonerations in the US
involve eyewitness misidentification?
And how can what we've seen turn
into something we never saw?
[intro]
I need you to… point to the shape that rolled
over your foot on the evening of March 14th,
2015. Okay, this example seems stupid, but it
shows one of the many, many problems with witness
identification. Only one shape in the lineup
comes close to the description of the suspect,
the choice is obvious. Only a circle
can roll! Now this lineup requires an
actual identification of size and color.
But here’s a question. How do you even get
to a lineup? First, you need a description.
Jennifer Thompson studied pages of ears, chins,
and noses so police could reconstruct her
attacker's face using an IdentiKit. In
1984, that was a sketch on paper -- now
the IdentiKit is digital. The hand-drawn facial
composite looked nearly perfect to her. Now the
police had a picture of the suspect that
could be broadcast on the local news.
Here’s the problem.
Some witnesses are amazing -- their
autobiographical memory of an event is flawless.
But then there’s the rest of us, and Hugo
Münsterberg wrote the book on how what we forget
and what we don’t know becomes an
illusion that replaces reality.
In 1908, Münsterberg published “On the Witness
Stand,” a collection of articles and essays about
psychological factors that affect trial outcomes.
What’s more persuasive than a witness pointing to
a defendant and swearing they did it? Münsterberg
insisted THAT gold standard of evidence in a trial
was actually… really untrustworthy.
Trials pre-date the ancient Greeks,
and while we’ve always known witnesses could lie,
only recently do we understand how easy it is to
THINK you’re telling the truth
when your brain is just… wrong.
Münsterberg suggested that justice often
miscarried due to the “treachery of human
memory” -- and to prove it, he pointed the
finger at himself. He wasn’t just some academic
pontificating on criminal justice theory -- he
was robbed, and as a witness, he messed it all up.
It went like this: He testified under oath that
burglars entered his house through a window. They
actually came in through the cellar. He said they
left a clock packed in paper. It was wrapped in a
tablecloth. He gave a complete list of garments
that were stolen; it turns out they took 7 more
than he said. He claimed he found candle wax on
the 2nd floor… but the wax drippings were actually
in the attic. Finally, he reported 2 burglars.
But maybe it was just 1 -- he had no way to tell.
Münsterberg had given over 3,000 academic lectures
and not once had to use note cards. His mind and
memory were amazing. But he admitted that he’d
rushed into the house and surveyed it all quickly,
noting after the fact that his brain filled in
the gaps for him. The burglar was eventually
caught breaking into another house, and they
found Münsterberg’s jacket in his apartment.
But the fact is -- the world’s expert on witness
reliability -- was almost completely wrong.
He said, “I felt myself somewhat alarmed
in seeing how many illusions had come in.”
So…
If the pioneer of witness reliability
scholarship couldn't overcome
his illusions, what chance did a college student
traumatized by a violent sexual assault have?
Police presented Jennifer Thompson with a photo
lineup of 6 men. They told her that the suspect
might not even be in the lineup -- but she
figured if he wasn’t there, why would they
bother? She recognized one of the photos and
chose Ronald Cotton with absolute certainty.
A week later, Jennifer recognized the same man in
a physical lineup. To her, the parts that didn’t
match her memory made him even guiltier -- like
he’d changed his hair to purposely deceive her.
The photo lineup reinforced her mental image
of her attacker, and anti-proof became proof.
Police confirmed that she’d chosen the
same man in both lineups. She said,
"It was him. There was no doubt in my mind."
Did you feel absolutely certain? Absolutely
certain. Well, what was said to me afterwards was,
“That’s the same person you picked out in
the photo lineup.” So in my mind I thought,
“Bingo! I did it right!”
So if that’s the case… How can
the truth compete with that?
“Estimator variables” are the parts of eyewitness
identification that police can’t control. So like,
cross-racial ID’s tend to be less accurate
than ID’s within a witness’s race. That isn’t
the police’s fault. People think different
things, and they just plain see different
things -- from an optical illusion to the colors
of a dress. But the real enemy of memory is time.
Hermann Ebbinghaus’s forgetting curve
provides a visual representation
of how quickly your memory can
erode -- and as early as the 1880’s
his equation expressed the vulnerability of
memory over time. But forgetting over time
is only half the problem -- the other
half is teaching yourself the lie.
Every time you re-tell your story to police,
to a lawyer, to a journalist, to a friend,
you’re essentially engaging in
the spaced repetition of practice.
You’re learning. Your memories get clearer,
almost like memorizing lines for a play.
So the longer it’s been, the more
you forget. The more you forget,
the more you invent. The more you repeat, the more
confident you are -- whether it’s true or not.
Jennifer Thompson said, “If
there was a death penalty,
I wanted Ronald Cotton to get it. I would pull
the switch if they let me.” When she pointed
her finger at Cotton to identify him during the
trial, she said she wished it had been a gun.
Ronald Cotton had become her attacker in
her mind through unconscious transference.
But there was no physical evidence -- no
fingerprints, no clothing, no fibers from
the victim’s apartment -- linking Ronald Cotton
to the crime. He maintained his innocence and
refused to entertain a plea bargain. He was
convicted based largely on Jennifer’s testimony.
3 years later, Jennifer Thompson came face
to face with her actual attacker -- and
didn’t even notice.
Ronald Cotton was given a new trial -- that’s
great, right? WRONG -- this time he also faced
charges for another assault and burglary from
that same night. Meanwhile, he’d met a man in
prison who looked a lot like Jennifer’s original
composite sketch -- and he looked so similar to
Ronald Cotton that other inmates couldn’t tell
them apart. Bobby Poole lived in the same town as
Ronald and Jennifer, and he was currently serving
a sentence for sexual assault. If all of that
wasn’t enough to raise suspicions, he’d literally
confessed to other inmates that he assaulted her.
Ronald’s lawyers called Bobby Poole
as a witness in the new trial. Poole
denied everything. Jennifer Thompson had wanted
to be the one to personally execute Ronald Cotton,
but when she was in the same courtroom as her
real attacker, the man whose face she’d studied,
she didn’t recognize him at all. Ronald was
convicted again and sent back to prison.
Richard Rosen, a professor at UNC-Chapel Hill,
and lawyer Tom Lambeth took on Ronald’s case.
They secured the DNA analysis that wasn’t
available in 1984. Ronald insisted that
he'd be cleared -- and the stakes were
high. A DNA match would cement his guilt.
Ronald wasn’t lying. The tests showed that not
only was Ronald innocent, but that Bobby Poole
was the attacker -- and over 10 years after
first being arrested, Ronald Cotton was free.
Jennifer didn’t dispute the DNA findings. She
knew she’d been proven wrong. She wasn’t defensive
about it; she was horrified. She said, “I had
to tell people not only was I was a rape victim,
but a rape victim with an extremely bad memory
and someone had to pay 11 years for that.
I wondered how I could have been so stupid.”
Jennifer was not stupid. During the attack she
actually convinced Poole to get rid of his knife,
then outwitted him by offering to get him a
drink and using the distraction to escape.
She just fell prey to the
vulnerabilities all witnesses have and
a few simple changes can drastically
improve witness reliability.
Lineups that offer a range of similar choices
are most effective -- that way suspects can’t
stand out. And making lineups sequential, so one
photo at a time is compared to a witness’s memory
instead of being compared to one
another, is even more effective.
Police need to make it clear to witnesses that
the suspect might not be there -- and the cops
who make the lineup shouldn’t be the ones who
administer it. That ‘double blind’ process
ensures police can’t give any verbal or non-verbal
cues to the witness to influence their choice.
Recording the lineup solidifies the record,
and police should ask witnesses to detail
their level of confidence in their choice.
But Jennifer Thompson would’ve
said 100%, and advancing science
was the only thing that saved
Ronald Cotton from a life in prison.
“In my mind, I was sure of what I saw. Um.
Thinking back on it, uh, I don’t know
that I would’ve done anything different.”
Jennifer and Ronald are friends now.
He never blamed her for being wrong.
They’ve given talks together nationwide,
their families are close, and they even end
phone conversations by saying “Love you.”
Half the states in the US have instituted some
form of eyewitness identification reform. But
can we make sure what happened to both Ronald
Cotton and Jennifer Thompson never happens again?
Probably not. Hugo Münsterberg was right --
from biological limitations to systematic error,
the moment our eyes and ears capture
something, the truth is vulnerable.
We can get better, but we'll never be perfect.
2,200 years ago, the Roman playwright
Plautus said that “1 eyewitness is worth
10 ear witnesses.” People attest to the truth
by saying they saw something with their own two
eyes. They’ll tell you that something is
so good you need to see it to believe it.
But the truth is… sometimes you
need to believe it to see it.
And as always, thanks for watching.